mais moi j'en ai une sur sur bien
entendu votre point de vue sur une autre
concentration parce que vous êtes très
actif
ici à chaque fois que les propriétaires
de médias n'étaient pas concernés
directement par la fusion tf1 m6 il nous
disait
je suis pas je suis pas content j'ai
rien à dire où je suis plutôt pour vous
connais votre position puisque vous avez
déjà réalisé quatre recours contre
l'éventuelle fusion outre tf1 m6 trois
des quatre ont été rejetées et la
dernière a été réalisée la semaine
dernière pour une question prioritaire
de constitutionnalité
pouvez vous nous expliquer la raison de
tous ses recours en justice est votre
opinion sur ce dossier pas seulement
opinion comme citoyen mais comme acteur
concurrents de deux de ses médias alors
le premier élément c'est que ces
procédures étaient liées quand même une
petite spécificité une petite bizarrerie
du sérieux du
déjà je me suis jamais il expliqué ou
publiquement sur le sujet donc là pour
ça que je veux je sais mais ça ne va pas
faire beaucoup d'attention à ce que vous
allez dire que ce serait la première
fois que vous même
dit 7 cette expression
sur le fond du sujet donc ces recours le
principal recours était de contester
le déroulé le souhaitent déroulement de
cette procédure devant les autorités
françaises mais bien mais vous avez plus
confiance dans votre pays la vérité de
vous dire qu'un peu que nous on annonce
cette fusion qui est quelque chose quand
même de lure d'incroyablement lourd dans
notre paysage et cette fusion
sera décidé par des autorités
indépendantes à paris cette fusion avait
à peine annoncé que le président de
l'art comme nous dit tout va bien
circulé on était censé être auditionné
avant même de nous avoir auditionné tout
va bien circuler la ministre de la
culture nous dit tout va bien circuler
la présidente de l'autorité de la
concurrence dit on va garder elle est
virée donc et à un moment on se dit on
n'est pas top top en confiance vous
pouvez nous dire elle est virée alors
là on l'a auditionné oui à différentes
façons de virer mais vous votre point de
vue c'est que c'est la raison pour
laquelle elle n'est plus alors qu'elle
souhaitait continuer
qu'elle n'a pas été renouvelé écoutez
vous a été très direct je dirais qu'on
fasse dès ce premier vous les approches
pas je vous demandais ce que vous
confirmez que c'est votre opinion mon
opinion personnelle sans avoir aucune
forme d'information me laisse penser
qu'elle a été virée liée à une absence
de position c'est-à-dire lié au fait
qu'elle souhaitait faire son boulot
normalement sur ce sujet et pour donner
des exemples on donne des exemples donc
si vous voulez à partir de ce moment là
je suis pas complètement confortable de
me dire mon pays est une grande
démocratie je crois dans sa justice mais
parfois dans ces autorités indépendantes
j'ai un petit doute quand le soutien de
cette opération qui est incroyablement
complexe en terme de concurrence
est soutenue par des gens qui
normalement devraient faire preuve d'un
peu plus de réserve
juste pour mieux comprendre votre pensée
là vous dit c'est pas la justice l'ex
terrasses et des autorités indépendantes
vous avez parlé même dac de
non-renouvellement or qui pour vous
diriger ces autorités des pentes
puisqu'elles sont considérés comme
indépendants qui aurait intérêt de façon
de façon coordonnée puisqu'il ya le tour
était la concurrence vous remettez en
cause l'art comme et son attitude qui
oui qui nettoie
les gens qui ont intérêt à être bien vus
ou bien soutenu dans ses médias tous les
gens qui ont vu qu'ils ont intérêt à
mélanger de la voir se veut ce pouvoir
sur ces autorités l'état accorde homme
nommé voilà je crois enfin je ne sais
pas qui nomme les présidents ses
sonorités je pense que le sénat lui même
un certain nombre de membres dans ces
autorités qui ensuite nomme le président
donc si vous voulez il ya un sujet
collectif je ne sais pas qui nomme alors
quand je sais l'autorité de la
concurrence je ne sais pas qui choisit
le président je crois que c'est une
décision politique là dans ce cadre mais
si vous voulez on stationné l'état c'est
l'état c'est un chef état et c'est un
gouvernement donc vous nous dites que
l'état de nous poursuivre et poursuivre
non non je vous en prie donc si vous
voulez à partir de ce moment là on n'est
absolument pas confortable à se dire on
va rester à paris avec un risque d'
intervention devant ces autorités
indépendantes et on a envie de quelque
chose de juste on a envie de quelque
chose de juste parce que ces deux
groupes sont ultra dominant en france
ultra dominant dans le fait de nous
amener de l'information et c'est ultra
domination normalement
économique en termes de pluralisme
devrait
susciter un certain nombre
d'interrogations qui n'ont globalement
peu été suscitée si vous regardez assez
peu d'opposition à ce sujet là est assez
peu de position sur ce sujet là et donc
à partir de ce moment là le si vous
prenez la totalité de ce sujet vous
dites ok ces gens veulent fusionner
franchement pour le groupe tf1 c'est un
coût économique génial vous nous on est
quatre dans les télécoms on n'arrive pas
à passer à 3 on pense par régulation
n'est pas sûr que ça puisse passer un
jour là à passer de deux groupes privés
dominant à un groupe privé dominant
création d'un monopole c'est un truc
fantastique donc c'est un coût
économique et bravo aussi des armes
qu'ils y arrivent parce que c'est un
coût économique exceptionnelle et je
pense qu'ils le font uniquement pour ça
les autres problèmes c'est pas leur
sujet le sujet c'est des commerçants des
bons commerçants et les bons commerçants
ils veulent gagner de l'argent et donc
leur sujet ce n'est pas un contrôle de
du pluralisme de l'audience où la
publicité dans ce pays leur idée c'est
allons gagner de l'argent pourquoi pas à
partir de ce moment là vous avez à vous
interroger sur un certain nombre de
sujets
le premier élément qu'on va vous dire
ces groupes sont en grave difficulté ils
sont graves difficultés ça va très très
mal il risque de disparaître vous
prendriez une grande responsabilité
messieurs si vous ne soutenez pas c'est
moi centration grande responsabilité on
est à la limite de la menace écoutez moi
la grande responsabilité ne sais pas où
aller donc on prend ces groupes les
chiffres sont assez claires je pense
qu'on folle et faut les lire parce qu'à
un moment les chiffres de ces groupes
ils viennent de publier leurs résultats
ils sont très gentils ou les incitait
nous mêmes ouais non mais vous allez
voir c'est mieux que ce que vous pensez
que l'on vous a on vous a cité des
groupes décident des chiffres un peu
réduit leur résultat net a quasiment été
doublé entre 2017 et 2021 158 millions
de résultat net en 2010 7 280 dre des
millions de résultat net pour m6 en 2021
ga tf1 souleimane la main en soi c'est
pas normal de gagner de l'argent sur les
médias on nous avait même dit que
c'était votre je suis entièrement
d'accord avec vous monsieur le président
messieurs s'est extrêmement bien mais
pas quand on veut se concentrer parce
que quand bien se concentrer il faut une
situation exceptionnelle pour créer un
monopole dans un pays il faut une
situation exceptionnelle la création
d'un monopole et on va en parler après
c'est extrêmement grave donc ils n'ont
pas de problèmes financiers vous allez
me dire oui mais attendez ils ont un
problème d'audience ils ont un problème
d'audience un problème d'audience
l'audience de tf1 en dix ans elle n'a
pas bougé n'a pas bougé l'audience de m6
en dix ans elle a progressé de ces deux
groupes ont vu des audiences pour un
stabilisé et l'autre progresser vous dit
ouais mais quand même il ya un fx qui
est en train d'arriver mais netflix
n'est pas en concurrence avec tf1 m6 et
m6 est en concurrence avec canal+ c'est
un truc payants contre un truc gratuit
netflix à 10 millions d'abonnés en
france canal en a eu 9 millions je crois
le chiffre d'affaires qu'à l'aller celui
de supérieur au chiffre d'affaires de
netflix c'est une blague c'est une vaste
blague après on va vous dire c'est
youtube mais c'est quoi youtube c'est
des gens qui postent leurs vidéos ça n'a
rien à voir c'est incomparable la
publicité que vous allez faire sur des
médias digitaux c'est quoi c'est un truc
ultra ciblée c'est à dire que je veux
toucher les femmes de 55 ans qui habite
dans tel quartier c'est ça la pub en
digital la force de tf1 m6 c'est une
puissance s'est écrasé comment je touche
10 millions de personnes comment je mets
mon spot dans hp y est je touche 12
millions de personnes à un instant donné
c'est ça c'est cette force et puissance
et vous avez besoin de cette force et
puissance et elle est archi nécessaire
mais quand vous mettez c'est même
puissante et vous consolidez les deux
seuls médias qui ont ces puissances en
france vous créer des problèmes quels
problèmes vous créer les problèmes que
vous créez ils sont de différentes
natures vous créez un problème très
naturellement sur le marché de la
publicité le marché de la publicité ça
on l'a entendu non voulait pas entendu
de cette manière là je vais vous dire
quel est le problème le vrai problème de
cette concentration c'est que vous
enlevez le
la possibilité de réguler les gars
femmes et ça ça va beaucoup plus loin
que ce que l'on peut dire ça va beaucoup
plus loin qu'on peut dire ça c'est un
sujet majeur ne pourra plus régulé les
gaffes ah ben si vous allez au bout de
cette concentration et un deuxième truc
et ce serait déjà du mal à les réguler
mais je sais pas puisque madame le
l'ancien président de l'autorité de la
concurrence elle a quand même envoyé un
pur à 100 millions de condamnation juste
motionnaire bien sûr juste pour éclairer
ce que ce que vous suggérez là c'est
quelque chose que j'ai suggéré dans une
audition c'est qu'à part si on prend le
marché pertinent mêlant le numérique le
digital à ce moment là la part ultra
dominant qu'avaient les gars femmes sur
le marché du numérique se diminue en
pourcentage et donc les régulations
forte que qu'on faisait quand ils
étaient les seuls sur le numérique
ne seront plus les mêmes puisqu'ils
seront diluées dans une proportion plus
importante l'ensemble des éléments du
débat à cela on ne répond que les 80 %
de recettes publicitaires détenus par
google facebook et maintenant un fait
amazon ne sont pas du tout régulé donc
je pense qu'il faut pour étendre les
entendez président l'autorité de la
concurrence oui je vais vous leur posez
la question vous allez poursuivre mais
mais il ya quelque chose que vous me
dites pas dans votre réponse
je pour que vous l'intégrer à votre
argumentation c'est dans ces recours et
dans cette motivation vous avez beaucoup
de passion pour nous l'expliquer
c'est qu'est ce qu'est ce qui vous
dérange par rapport à vos propres
activités je l'entends rapport à vous
vos propres activités puisque vous
n'êtes pas dans la télévision en
concurrence sur ces 10 millions qui
veulent atteindre c'est donc sur la
téléphonie non non non non non pas du
tout monsieur président financier pour
iliad mais il ya un risque financier
colossal pour yann c'est une
augmentation du prix on vous parle de
300 millions de synergies on va les
prendre là dessus je pense qu on a 100
millions de synergies c'est la hausse
des prix la publicité et ses 100
millions de marge et ça c'est un truc
qui touchent toutes mes activités et
donc si vous voulez en tant que
industriels j'ai cette problématique là
et c'est problématique là elle est pour
moi significative la hausse des prix de
la publicité elle est directe elle est
immédiate et et ça ne peut pas exister
autrement et je voulais 10 tf1 est la
chaîne la plus puissante d'europe en
terme d'audience m6 la chaîne la plus
rentable d'europe c'est ça le truc c'est
ça la réalité on vous dit parfois
regardé aux états unis tout le monde à
consolider la première chaîne de
télévision américaine à 7% d'audience y
en a plein d network aux us donc si vous
voulez en termes de publicité vous allez
pardon créé un monstre qui va dominer ce
marché est en fait qu on est en train de
vous dire c'est que le marché de la
publicité
ces marchés du temps de cerveau
disponible parce que c'est quoi la
logique de mettre les mots clés sur
google dans ce même marché c'est quoi le
bout qu'on met pas la presse au passage
beaucoup mais pas la presse pour qu'on
m'ait pas l'affichage pour qu'on met pas
tout et au bout on est en train de vous
dire notre marché c'est le temps de
cerveau disponible c'est le temps de
cerveau sur lequel vous avez des trucs
et dans lequel on va vous mettre de la
publicité et ça c'est un sujet
incroyablement problématique parce que
c'est une hausse des prix et en tant
qu'industriel je vais avoir cette hausse
des prix parce que je ne peux pas me
passer de tf1 je peux pas me passer m6
dans la publicité et à partir de ce
moment là sur ce sujet là je suis
attaqué je distribue ses chaînes c'est
quand même un truc fantastique ce sont
des chaînes gratuites mais nous les
rémunérer aujourd'hui nous avons ces
deux groupes ce sont les deux seuls
groupes à qui nous payons les chaînes
linéaires gratuites sont des chaînes
gratuites
on leur achète
demain aujourd'hui je peux couper une de
ses chaînes nous avons coupé bfm à un
moment on avait il souhaité nous faire
payer nous avons pas souhaité payer on a
coupé des fêtes le groupe vivendi a
coupé tf1 à un moment où on souhaitait
les faire payer ou n'ont pas sauté payer
mais qui aura le coupage le coupé tf1 et
m6 en même temps parce que dans votre
négociation ils voudront imposer quelque
chose d'inacceptable personnes donc en
tant que distributeur la télévision vous
en ai parlé au travers d box triple play
ouais le premier ou deuxième en france
je suis touchée dans cette activité là
puisque je risque de disparaître dans
cette activité la troisième activité en
termes de production du visuel
producteurs audiovisuels
quand vous produisez quand le média one
produit un film comme bac nord bac noria
d un certain nombre d'endroits vous
aller collecter des recettes vous allez
voir tf1 et m6 pour poser vos questions
pour leur dire combien vous mettez-vous
tf1 et m6 pour financer sa et bien
partir de ce moment là la même manière
vous n'avez pu ce marché ouvert et ses
quatre mille producteurs qui sont en
france vont souffrir certains vont
disparaître et pourtant ces producteurs
ils ont fait bout oh que non pas fait
tf1 m6 tf1 et m6 sont restés tf1
notamment il restait un groupe français
local bertelsmann avait fait le boulot
en commençant à avoir la distribution
partout c'est quoi le secret netflix je
produis un contenu je le dis foz dans le
monde entier c'est ça le truc c'est pas
parce que vous allez relier tf1 et m6
demain vous allez avoir mis leurs
productions savait exactement l'inversé
ça va être exactement la verse ils vont
négocier la production moins cher au
contraire vous allez faire baisser
lequel la qualité de ses productions et
tout ça nous amène à des choses
problématique mais je vous rajoute le
sujet parce que c'est le sujet de cette
commission le pluralisme je voulais dit
tout à l'heure un article du monde il
est lui pas cent mille personnes un bon
article dit lu par 5000 personnes tous
les soirs tf1 20h05 à 6 millions de
personnes 19 45 m6 trois millions et
demi de personnes vous rajoutez rtl
c'est quoi la puissance du monde face au
goût à la puissance du groupe tf1 m6
réunis c'est un rapport de 1 à 100 et je
pense que vous avez quelque chose là qui
est extrêmement important ce qui est
important de réguler c'est pas la
concentration dans le sens des gens
récupèrent des médias les agrège etc
c'est quelle est votre part quel est
votre puissance dans la diffusion
d'informations à l'instant présent
quelle est la puissance et votre poids
là dedans parce que ça c'est là où est
le danger pour la démocratie si un
instant de raison
des tirs
sans papiers très opposés à la fusion
passionné aussi c'est pas gentil de me
couper monsieur le président je vais
avoir jamais subi face à une liste de
questions de sénateurs qui va nous poser
le jeu et demandez à laure finissez
votre propos vis je vous ai coupé les
donc je répondais pour le plus rageant
parce qu'on a des questions à vous poser
le pluralisme surtout sur une chaîne
comme tf1 qui dans l'histoire a montré
que le pluralisme était un sujet qu'on
va dire complexe et le lancement de free
mobile un jour je sais pas pourquoi tf1
oubliez donc heureusement d'autres
médias se sont moqués d'eux et à la fin
ils ont fini par parler trois secondes
sur leurs antennes on a rendu des
dizaines de milliards pouvoir de
dizaines de milliards d'euros de pouvoir
d'achat aux français collectivement mais
parle de l'existence de free mobile donc
on arrive là dessus et tf1 ont envie
d'en parler et c'est le quotidien dans
le cadre de la fusion m6 tf1 m6 vous dit
un truc pourri sur tf1 vous n'ait pu
vous inviter chez tf1 vous n'êtes plus
invité vaut celle ci
c'est puissance ce poids incroyable mais
vous verrez jamais vous m'auriez vu sont
toutes les antennes de france jamais ni
chez tf1 nicher et si jamais ça n'existe
pas que j'aie jamais reçu une invitation
de l'élite et pourtant vous avez des
interviews de martin bouygues dans le
monde wire si vous voulez ses
conceptions des médias elle les
problématiques et quand vous donner plus
de puissance pour le pluralisme c'est un
problème bien que je pense je vous dis
c'est une très belle opération pour le
groupe qui prendra le contrôle de
l'ensemble félicitations c'est une super
opération économique et je pense que
pour nous en tant qu'industriels et en
tant que citoyen c'est un énorme
problème est que ça ne tient pas alors
réellement une le choc d'une
vérification par des autorités
indépendantes une des conséquences
possibles de la fusion tf1 m6 serait la
remise sur le marché d'un certain nombre
de chaînes en vertu de l'application de
la loi de 2,86 tf1 et m6 ont évoqué
sister tf1 série séries films tfx ou
google y est ce que angie votre
structure dans les médias ou média one
donc vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
serait intéressé par reprendre une ou
plusieurs de ses chaînes mais à partir
du moment où je pense que ça ne peut pas
exister je le sujet ne se pose pas je ne
pense pas non sens je voulais ce que
veut dire le jeu peut être que média one
regarde je ne sais pas mais je à
l'instant vous vous ne regardez pas à
travers non aujourd'hui ça me paraît
tellement aberrant que si vous voulez je
ne peux même pas me projeter dans ce
monde
[Musique]